Good evening everyone.
I hope everybody can hear me.
Speakers are working fine and everybody
can hear.
Listen,
thank you very much for being here.
It's lovely,
wonderful to see such a large audience
here in Carlton Place Tonight and why to
indeed.
Thank everybody for being here.
Um,
and I'll just check with deal facial
timer.
Bruso did we get it within five minutes?
All right.
Uh,
for those who don't know,
my name is Randy Hillier.
I'm the member of provincial parliament
for landmark frontneck,
Lennox and Addington.
And of course I represent this area at
Queen's Park and I'm trust and expect it
and hope that everyone will find this
evening.
Very informative,
very interesting and very enjoyable.
Um,
look to just recognize a few other
people who are here this evening for
tonight.
Um,
and I see that we have councillor fake
Campbell and councilor Brian Dowdle from
beckwith township in the audience this
evening.
Thank you very much.
We also have the,
uh,
deputy we've and Reeve,
deputy revshare and Musso and Reeve
Richard Kid from beckwith township here
this evening.
And last but not least,
uh,
his worship and mayor of commonplace,
Louie and tonight has joined us this
evening as well.
Thank you very much for being here
tonight.
[inaudible]
I hope I didn't miss anybody.
Did I miss somebody?
Oh,
pardon me.
Uh,
the mayor of Mississippi Mills,
Shawn Mclaughlin is here.
He snuck in.
I don't know how he got in here without
me,
Xenia,
Sean,
but uh,
thanks for being here as well.
Um,
I should also mention just a couple
items before we begin to see evening.
Um,
there is a washrooms outside the main
doors and to the right femoral,
the uh,
looking for the washrooms.
There's also a,
um,
trying to keep the flashes and the
recordings to a minimum.
We do have a couple of photographers
here tonight.
Um,
there,
this evening's event is being a fully
recorded,
a video and audio and will be published
online in its entirety.
So,
uh,
don't need to do any other recording
that will all magically appear on the
Internet sometime tomorrow,
I would imagine.
So.
Um,
and it will of course will be free and
available to everybody after tonight's
presentations.
Um,
and I,
and I guess I should also state that
this is not a partisan or political
event tonight.
Um,
we will have a question and answer
period after Dr. Peterson has made his
presentation.
And I know many people here know much
about Dr. Peterson.
He is widely read and,
uh,
knowledgeable and in saint full on a
great many subjects.
But we would like to see the questions,
uh,
um,
relevant to tonight's topic.
Um,
so,
and with that,
I think I'll
just start a little bit about myself.
Before being elected,
before entering politics,
I like many other people was
increasingly getting disappointed with
the,
with the way government was conducting
itself with the ever increasing
government laws,
their rules,
their regulations that in my view were
unduly infringing on what I considered
my own personal jurisdiction,
my own personal responsibility.
And,
um,
and also how these increasing role of
government was shifting and altering
society in ways that I felt
uncomfortable with,
that I felt were contrary to my beliefs
and my values.
And like most people,
um,
I grumbled about it and grumbled and
spoke with other people who grumbled
about things.
But we didn't do very much about it.
We just board green and bore and the the
ever increasing role of government.
But back in 2002 very fortunately,
I came across a few other fellows who
had very much same attitudes and values
as myself.
And in 2002,
four of us,
four of us met around a kitchen table,
um,
at Moreau and Ruth Bose home owed on the
concession for Ramsey.
And we decided that it was time to act.
Now,
none of us actually knew what that
meant.
None of us had actually ever done
anything about government,
but we knew that we needed to speak out
and we knew that we needed to make a
difference.
So we formed,
formed a group and we called it the
land,
our land owners association.
And I was asked to be the spokesperson
and the president of that New
Association of four people.
And then of course we said,
that's great.
Now what do we do?
Well,
we decided to hold a meeting not far
from here.
Indeed.
Oh,
lab over in beckwith township was their
first meeting of the landmark landowners
association.
We went around the area,
we put up posters on Hydro Poles,
poles and telephone poles.
We put posters up in the general stores
and the stores around the area.
And um,
and we also send a few letters to the
newspapers,
um,
indicating what our concerns were.
And we wanted to see,
you know,
because we really had no idea if there
was anybody else who thought like we
did.
We knew there was a four of us,
but we didn't know if there was any
others.
So we held this meeting,
um,
decided to give it a goal.
And surprisingly the hall was packed in
Becker's township that night.
Um,
and people came,
they shared their stories.
The,
um,
shared that they had similar thoughts,
similar beliefs,
similar values.
And at the end of that night,
our association of four people became an
association of 90 people.
And within the next five years,
the Lennar glam donors would grow to
include chapters from around the
province
and a membership of 15,000 people.
People found a vehicle to speak out.
Through that association,
they found a vehicle to become involved
and to make a difference.
Excuse me.
Okay.
During those years,
we held many town halls in every corner
of the province.
We provided testimony at government
committee hearings.
We argued with politicians and
bureaucrats alike in many different
forms.
We had the Senate committee come out,
uh,
to murals house.
They wanted to hear more about our
stories.
Many people,
politicians and parties asked to meet
with us and we had politicians and
political parties knocking on our doors,
seeking our support and seeking our
advice.
Now,
many of you will that we didn't just
confine ourselves who the two,
the gentlemanly arts of diplomacy in
discussions with the landmark land
owners as well.
On occasion we did a take activism and
our voice to different heights.
We conduct conducted skits and plays at
farmer's markets.
We shuttered and closed down government
buildings.
We had a catalog action on Parliament
Hill.
We held tractor rallies and closed down
highways and bridges throughout the
province.
We were very fortunate that we had a
great many members with a great many
skills and also a lot of creativity and
passion for our subjects in our demand
for greater personal responsibility and
less government involvement.
In our property.
I learned many valuable lessons through
those years,
many which were quite contradictory to
the conventional wisdom.
The first lesson I learned is that we
have a mistaken belief that political
leaders are leaders.
It became clear to me that most
politicians are followers,
not leaders,
and that people must demonstrate and
she'll government and politicians alike,
that in order to change a policy,
change an activity or an issue,
politicians require a demonstration of
public support.
Political parties often use polling or
focus groups to determine where it's
safe to go.
And when I'm speaking about politics and
government,
I'm leaning more to the provincial and
federal side of politics as well.
I want to make that clear.
Municipal politics is very much,
of course,
it's not a party oriented system at
municipal level and there's a a great
many differences at the municipal level,
but political parties use that,
those focus groups and polling to try to
determine where it's safe for them to
go.
But in doing so,
it really negates in diminishes that
fundamental principle of representative
democracy,
elected people and parties speaking with
and knowing the pulse of their
communities,
their constituents,
their constituency,
but also it helping to lead and advocate
for change for the better.
In short,
democracy does not mean to government.
It does not mean politicians,
although they are both necessary
ingredients.
Representative democracy means you and
me.
It means us.
That's what representative democracy
must have for it to function properly.
It does not include the words they or
them.
It is you and I for a representative
democracy to work
the other lesson and I often often
during those days with the land owners,
I would be approached by people.
People would come up to me and many
venues and invariably they would say
something like,
along this line,
someone ought to do something about
this.
Always they would come up to me,
say someone ought to do something,
and that went on for quite a period of
time.
It took me a little while to catch on
that when they were saying someone they
met me or when they said someone,
it meant not them.
Right.
And,
and I did learn that,
you know,
I had listened to their suggestion and
their idea and when they told me then
someone ought to do something,
I would agree with them and say,
someone ought to.
And I know where you can find that
someone.
And they would look at me
with a questioning look and say,
well,
who?
And I would say,
look in the mirror and you will find
that very someone that you're looking
for.
And until you do look in the mirror,
you will never find that someone who
ought to do something.
And that was a,
um,
it actually worked.
It actually got people,
it motivated people to actually think
about what they were saying and think
about what they were doing and what they
wanted to do.
I could go on and on about the lessons
that I learned,
um,
the rewarding actions and activities and
the successes that we enjoyed with the
land owners.
But tonight I know that there's someone
who has a far broader,
far deeper understanding and
understanding of the importance of civic
engagement,
the understanding,
and also the thoughts and knowledge of
how to help find people to find their
voice and to become influential.
Tonight.
We are honored to have that individual
here tonight.
He is a professor of psychology at the
University of Toronto.
He's a clinical psychologist.
He is bringing knowledge and insight of
humanity to tens of thousands of people
through his online activities and is
free university lectures.
And I'll tell you,
I'm not one to generally watch
university lectures,
let alone,
uh,
lectures on psychology.
But I started watching his lectures on
maps of meaning and I was astonished,
you know,
uh,
the first one was like two and a half
hours in length and I watched the first
five of them and I think it was the
first five of them was a,
well part of it.
It'll do over 10 hours.
I'm not going to get into all the
details over 10 hours,
but these lectures was 10 hours of
breaking down in dissecting and
understanding a story.
The Story of Pinocchio.
No,
I found that amazing that I,
that I could watch these lectures first.
But you know,
I,
I've,
I know about,
I know the story of Pinocchio.
It wasn't that interesting to me as a
kid,
the hub,
and it certainly wouldn't have taken me
10 hours to describe the story to
anybody else.
But anyway,
so that's just an aside.
If you want to really buy something,
I find that interesting.
But I also first came across this
individual years ago.
Uh,
I'm an avid watcher of TV,
owes a agenda with Steve Pakan,
um,
gets into a lot of provincial policy
and,
uh,
I find Steve Pagan,
the,
um,
very credible journalist and uh,
often this fellow would be on Steve
Pagans agenda show and I would watch
with interest,
uh,
when he was there.
So,
but in my estimation,
this gentleman is one of Canada's
foremost thinkers and with a very
significant twist.
He has a courage and the conviction to
speak out against some of those false
woods of conventional wisdom and
political correctness.
I know he has much to offer,
a lot of wisdom and
it is my pleasure to welcome to
commonplace and Dilana County,
Dr. Jordan B.
Peterson.
They're on this tonight.
You can hear me.
Okay,
here we go.
Thank you Mr [inaudible] for the
introduction and also for the
invitation.
So not everyone will invite me places.
So it's nice when an invitation shows
up.
Yeah,
yeah.
And when I'm actually allowed to speak,
that's also good.
So I have a habit of not preparing my
talks until really the last minute.
And I mean that's not exactly true
because I've been thinking about what
I'm going to talk to you about tonight
for a very long time.
But I really only got the title for this
talk firmly in place about half an hour
ago.
And,
and one of the things I'd like to do
when I'm speaking to people is to tell
them what I'm thinking about,
not what I've already thought about,
you know,
and certainly not what I know,
but what I'm thinking about,
what I'm trying to figure out.
And so one of the things that's happened
to me over the last year,
somewhat surprisingly,
is that I'd been invited to speak in
front of a lot of conservative groups
and,
uh,
a lot of them were conservative groups
that were composed of young people.
And that was interesting,
you know,
because conservatism
isn't something that's necessarily all
that easy to sell to young people
because they tend not to be that
conservative to begin with.
Um,
conservatism also tends to have quite a
lot to do with things that you shouldn't
do and instead of things that you might
be allowed to do.
And so there's a restrictive element of
it.
It's also perhaps less attractive to
young people then it might be,
people do tend to get more conservative
as they get older as their personality
shift.
And so,
but what I saw was very interesting
because I saw,
and then this was particularly true of
young men.
Um,
and I,
I haven't quite puzzled that out yet,
but you know,
I would talk about what was going on in
the universities and what I thought
might constitute a reasonable antidote
to that.
And that was not only in the
universities but also politically,
but,
and that was both the adoption of
responsibility instead of the incredible
and constant stress that's being placed
on rights and also the responsibility of
the citizen to speak forward what he or
she believed to be true or at least to
not speak what they knew to be false,
which is at least a good place to start.
And one of the things I found so
remarkable was that this was actually a
salable message to young people.
And that surprised me because you know,
you wouldn't necessarily think that you
would turn a lot of lights on any young
audience by talking to people about
truth and responsibility.
I think if you,
if you went to a marketing agency and
told them that that was going to be your
political message to young people,
they would tell you to go back and you
know,
flesh out another plan,
sketch out another plan.
But maybe young people have been talked
to enough about rights for maybe about
the next 15 decades.
That's what I would think.
And so maybe there's a hunger,
a rising among young people for
something that has a little bit more
respectability,
let's say a little bit more depth than
the constant emphasis on,
on
doing whatever you want,
whenever you want.
Let's,
let's put it that way.
The thing about that and the thing about
rights in general,
the idea of rights is that rights don't
really give you much direction,
right?
They,
they tell you what you are in principal
allowed to do,
but they don't really tell you what you
should do and it actually turns out that
you need to know what you should do
because you need to do something right.
People are active and our lives don't
have any meaning without something to do
and it and something that you should do.
It can't just be something that you want
to do that's too shallow.
There's no deep meaning.
There's no enduring,
there's no sustaining meaning in that.
It's just impulsiveness and [inaudible].
And maybe that's okay.
In some sense,
maybe that's entertaining and maybe
it's,
and maybe it's impulsively exciting and
fun and there's some,
there's some utility in that for life.
But life is a very difficult journey.
Let's say it involves a lot of suffering
and ill.
It involves a lot of,
of heavy existential weight.
And you need to be able to put something
of value up against that so that you can
withstand your life and you can stand up
with some dignity and you can contribute
to your community and you can feel that
you're a worthwhile person,
you know,
in spite of all the things that are,
that you're doing wrong and in spite of
all the problems that you have.
And so then people need to know what
they should do.
And one of the things they should do is
take responsibility.
And another thing they should do is try
to tell the truth because those two
things help them live proper lives and
then help society organize itself
properly.
And that's,
that's good.
That's good for everyone.
So,
and so it turns out that when you tell
young people that they're pretty damn
happy about that.
And so one of the things I thought I
would do tonight is talk about what
conservatives might have to offer to
young people as a saleable message.
You know,
because the other thing I've learned
over the last year,
and this was quite
revealing,
let's put it that way.
I'll start with a brief or story just as
a little intro to this.
In the last three weeks,
some of you may know that there was
quite a political storm that emerged,
particularly among journalists over the
issue of cultural appropriation.
A number of journalists got in real
trouble for transgressing the
politically correct norms in
relationship to cultural appropriation.
Tremendously ill defined.
And let's call it pathological concept.
We could start with that,
but,
but the thing that was so interesting,
and I think I probably talked to 10 of
Canada's top 20 journalists,
that would be a reasonable estimate.
Most of them in print,
but not all of them.
Every single one of them told me that
they were censoring themselves.
Or you think about that,
man,
that's no joke.
In a country like this and these people,
you'd think,
well,
if anyone has power,
they have power.
It's like,
well they don't really have power.
They have competence and influence and
that's not the same thing as power and
they're bloody afraid of being hung out
to dry if they say the wrong thing and
you think about where our damn country
is when the 10 most powerful journalists
in the country are afraid to write and
say what they think,
that's not a good thing,
man.
That's not a good thing.
I don't care what it is that they want
to say or think the fact that they're
not only did they tell me that they were
censoring themselves and that they felt
that they would be hung out to dry if
they said the wrong thing,
but they also told me that they were
being censored by their editors.
And so,
you know,
in a country that has a great tradition
and a tradition that's much longer than
this country has been around of freedom
and free speech and free press for us to
be in a situation now where our major
journalists are afraid that if they
misstep inappropriately in this new
found political landmine that they're
going to be done.
That is not good.
Right.
That's a bad diagnostic sign.
Okay,
well I said that story was a little
intro to the other story was going to
tell you.
And then,
so I've been fortunate enough over the
last several months to meet,
not the majority of the people who ran
for the leadership of the Federal
Conservative Party,
but most of them,
including the people,
the person who Andrew,
who recently won.
And uh,
they all told me the same thing,
which was also interesting was that the
conservatives were afraid to be
conservative.
And for exactly the same reason,
they were afraid that if they put
forward valid conservative perspectives
that they would be isolated and mobbed
and taken down and,
and that made them censor themselves and
not be willing to speak up.
And I thought,
and I told each of them when we
discussed this,
the same thing was if you guys are
afraid to talk,
you've already lost.
You want as well,
just pack up and go home.
It's done.
Now,
you know,
as a psychologist
[inaudible]
I gotta say I'm not making a case for
conservatism.
I'm not here to make a political case.
Right?
I'm here to make a philosophical and
psychological case and I think that's
what I've been doing all along.
It has political implications.
So I'm not saying that you should be
conservative or that conservative is the
only way to be cause I actually don't
believe that for for a variety of
reasons.
One of the reasons is that I know that
political belief is determined in large
part by temperament and personality and
that's very strongly biologically
influenced.
And so conservatives tend to be lower
and openness,
which is a trait associated with
creativity and higher in
conscientiousness,
which is a trait associated with
industriousness and orderliness.
They tend to make good managers and
administrators and lawyers,
they tend to make good conservative
business types.
That's,
that's their forte,
that's their niche.
And that's a valid place to be in a
valid thing to be.
And you know,
conservatives aren't so good at being
entrepreneurial.
They're not so good at being artistic
and creative.
That's not their niche.
That's more the niche of the liberal end
of the spectrum as far as I'm concerned,
for the political system to function
properly,
you need proper representation for all
the temperamental types and they need to
be engaged in dialogue.
So,
but the thing is is that when the
conservatives are saying,
well,
you know,
especially when they're perhaps thinking
about leading the damn party,
let's say that they're worried about
speaking their mind in a conservative
manner,
that's just not a good thing.
That means that something's gone wrong
with our political system and seriously
wrong.
You know?
And the other thing that,
another thing that I've noticed it
thing,
you know when,
when this all,
some of you may know and some of you may
not know that I made a couple of videos
back.
September 27th I woke up one night
because I couldn't sleep and I thought
are usually going right if I can't sleep
because I've got something to figure out
and,
but I've been playing with youtube
videos,
I've been putting my lectures online
since 2013 and by last April they had
about a million views.
And so I thought,
wow,
that's,
that's really something man.
You know,
like you write a book and you sell a
million copies,
you're one happy character.
And I thought I had a million views is a
very large number of views.
It really tuned me into the fact that
youtube was something completely other
than what I thought it was.
But anyways,
that night I thought,
oh,
I'll get up and make a video instead of
writing it down.
And this was a video about bill
[inaudible],
which by the way,
the Senate just passed,
right?
Half the Conservatives voted for it.
Despite the fact that the justice
minister was presented with an amendment
that clearly indicated that bill
[inaudible] would not infringe upon free
speech and refuse to consider the
amendment.
So that's where we are.
There's compelled speech is now,
the law in Canada isn't yet,
but it's going to be very soon and half
the conservatives voted for that damn
bill.
And I can tell you to,
you know,
people have gone after me for being,
anti-trans gender and bigoted and phobic
and all that nonsense that the left
tends to hurl at people.
It's not the case.
I read that damn legislation and I read
the policies surrounding it and I know
perfectly well that the way it's
formulated right now,
it will do more harm to the people it
purports to protect than good.
That'll take about 10 years to unfold.
But it's so incoherent.
And the,
the,
the principles upon which that
legislation and its surrounding policies
are based are so paradoxical and
contradictory that they will act
themselves out because that's what
happens with paradoxical beliefs and
tangled people up like the Matt,
like Thai tangled people up in them like
mad.
And we'll see that happen over the next
decade.
And it's partly because the people who
put bill six see 16 forward,
especially with regards to its
surrounding policies.
The ones that are detailed out on the
Ontario Human Rights Commission website
don't give a damn about transgender
people as far as I'm concerned there.
There's another agenda at work that's
driving their entire political force
forward.
And the transgender types were just
flavor of the month,
right?
They were poster boys for moving this
agenda forward.
And so the fact that the legislation
isn't going to do them any good,
you're the transgendered people,
any good isn't going to stop the people
who put the legislation forward.
So anyways,
I made these videos and I put them on a,
on youtube and well,
to say that they caused a storm is
somewhat of an understatement.
I mean,
it's just been,
I just,
I,
I don't even know what to think about.
It's completely an absolutely surreal
what,
what's happened to me.
All right,
good.
And as a consequence of that,
I mean,
I don't know how many people have
watched those original videos,
like 350,000 and I think now about 50
million people have watched videos
associated with this sequence of events
that I'm describing,
which is just 350,000 people watched the
testimony that I gave before the Senate
on bill [inaudible].
You bloody well know that the apocalypse
is close when 350,000 people around the
world watch a Canadian Senate hearing.
So I really,
I mean,
really what's going on man?
[inaudible]
so anyways,
you know,
so you know,
I said well the journalists are nervous
in the and the,
and the conservatives are nervous and,
and uh,
well then you know,
when I,
when I put myself out in and made these
videos,
which are really didn't expect to
attract much attention at all,
I just assumed that I was going to
clarify what I was thinking a little bit
and you know,
and see what happened.
I kind of a curious person now that'll
teach me but I'm kind of a curious
person.
And so,
um,
but then you know,
I also experienced firsthand what
happens when you do something like that.
Now Watch,
I got nailed right.
It got,
especially for about three months,
things were pretty up in the air at the
university sent me two letters telling
me that it,
it was so funny cause I remember I made
this video and I said,
you know,
under this new legislation,
making this video,
criticizing this legislation is probably
illegal.
And so then the unit and people of
course reacted to me as if I was
scaremongering,
which by the way,
was the right response.
When you hear someone in a stable
society stand up and say,
excuse me,
there's a,
there's something rotten at the base
here and it's affecting the manner in
which the legislation that our country
is producing is,
is,
is being rolled fourth,
when they say that you should think that
person is probably a charlotte and has
something wrong with them because look,
the culture works pretty good.
The country has worked really well for a
long period of time.
And so the logical initial response
should be,
yeah,
you think there's a fundamental problem,
why shouldn't we just assume that
there's a fundamental problem with you?
And one of the ways that you determine
that is you throw things out the person
metaphorically and see if any of them
stick.
Right?
So,
you know,
I was a big get to know homophobic and
transphobic and a racist.
That one,
I don't know where the hell that one
came from.
I think it was because I,
I criticized the two.
Uh,
what would you call reprehensible women
who started black lives,
the black lives matter movement,
Toronto.
It isn't because they're black.
It's because the reprehensible black or
white man,
if you're,
you're reprehensible.
That's sort of the definition of not
being racist.
Right?
So
anyways,
so,
so there were a couple of demonstrations
and then the press jumped on me to some
degree.
They didn't do too bad a job I didn't
think.
And then the university thankfully wrote
two letters saying that what I was doing
was probably illegal and that it
violated the,
the uh,
Ontario Human Rights Commission's
policies and probably the university's
policies as well as far as they were
concerned,
which really wasn't the case.
And the letters also contained a number
of untruths,
which I detailed because I read them on
Youtube too,
which is actually quite helpful and
handy that,
you know,
if someone writes me a letter that
purports to lay out a set of facts,
then I can just read it.
I don't even have to comment on it.
I can read it and let people make up
their own minds,
which they did so,
so well.
And so my job was in del in in doubt,
but the fact that the university went
after me actually turned out to be
extremely helpful.
Right.
Because I had said,
look under the provisions of this new
legislation and legislation like this
that's already in place in Canada,
what I am doing criticizing this bill is
probably illegal.
And everyone said,
no,
you're crazy.
You know you're,
there's something wrong with you.
You're off.
You're a,
you're a scaremonger on a rabble rouser
and all of that.
And then the university wrote a letter
saying what you did violate it,
you know,
the university policy and probably the
Ontario Human Rights Commission's
policies and the law.
And I thought,
great,
you had your lawyers take a look at it.
I couldn't have asked for a more
stronger statement,
a stronger statement in support of what
I had said,
especially because it certainly wasn't
written in support of what I had said.
So,
and then the journalists started to pay
attention to what I had actually looked
at and they read it and they thought,
Oh hey,
look at that,
that aren't dead.
Ontario Human Rights Commission website
policy mass is actually quite a nest of
spiders just like he said.
And so it turns out that there is
something rotten in the state of Denmark
and that's just not so good.
And so like this is a good country man.
That's why people want to come here.
It's one of the best countries in the
world.
Maybe it's the best country in the
I mean,
we don't want to get too high on her
horse about that.
And God,
aren't we fortunate,
but it's a pretty good place,
you know?
But it's not what it used to be.
And the people who are running it are
not who you think they are.
So for example,
provincially,
let's take it the title that the people
who follow Kathleen Wynne have is
liberal.
They are not liberals,
they are radicals and they're radicals
of a sword.
I used to work for the NDP when I was a
kid back in the 70s and the people who
are influential in Kathleen wins
government and who are making the sort
of policies that I regard is
particularly reprehensible,
are the kind of radical leftists that
the NDP working class socialists that I
knew in the 1970s would have regarded as
the,
as the unacceptable fringe of the
Socialist Party.
And they're now defunct.
They have now defined themselves as
centrist liberals.
They are not,
and what they're doing is not centrist
and it's not liberal.
And so that's another thing for the
conservative party to start thinking
about because you have a whole bunch of
liberals you could go out there and
capture because they've been abandoned
by their own party.
And that's for sure.
And it's something that should be taken
advantage of because well we need some
conservatives and we need some
socialists and maybe we need some
liberals and the Liberals and the
Conservatives are getting damn scarce
among the people who actually make
policy at not only at the provincial and
federal level but also at mid level.
Admitted at the top end of mid level
administration is everywhere as well and
that's not accidental.
It's partly because unbeknownst to the
majority of society for the last 30
years,
the damn universities have been doing
nothing but training and targeted
training,
radical leftist activists and if you
don't believe that you just go on the
web and look up like 10 women's studies
programs and read what they say.
You don't have to listen to me.
You don't have it.
I don't want you to believe me.
You just go out there and find it for
yourself.
And there the activism is devoted to a
certain key set of ends and one of them,
for example,
here's a word to remember.
Equity.
Okay,
that's replaced equality of opportunity.
It's like,
okay,
equality of opportunity.
That's a tough one to bring about.
You know,
you need a fair bit of government
intervention to bring about equality of
opportunity.
It's maybe it's a noble goal,
it's a tough one to attain.
But equity,
equity means equality of outcome and
you're seeing equity everywhere and
that's what it means.
And so the people who are pushing this
radical agenda are pushing things that
are,
that are inimicable to our traditions
and,
and practices of governance.
You know the Ontario social justice
tribunals,
because we have social justice tribunals
in Ontario,
they don't even day now to hide the damn
name.
The social justice tribunals are allowed
to suspend standard jurisprudential
practice in the pursuit of their aims.
It says that right in their policies.
Well you think about that re really
that's written in your policies.
You can just dispense with classic
jurisprudential tradition.
So what does that mean?
It means you can do any damn thing you
want.
And so those are the sorts of,
I would say subversive and fifth column
like organizations that are sprouting up
in our society everywhere.
It's not a good thing.
And so look,
when someone stands up and says there's
something wrong,
the first thing you should ask is what
makes,
why should I assume that you know what
the hell you're talking about?
That's a good question.
Well,
you investigate it and you find out
whether or not the person does know what
they're talking about.
And on the issue that I'm describing to
you tonight,
as far as I can tell,
I know what I'm talking about now.
People have been on my case about this
in a very serious way for quite a long
time and so far they haven't made any
inroads into arguments and most of the
time they're too damn cowardly to debate
me,
which is also something that's really
interesting because I put out public
calls constantly.
It's you want to debate about gender and
sex.
You just bring it on because that
happens to me,
happens to be an area of expertise for
me and I know the damn literature and if
you want to come out and make your case
that all the differences between men and
women are socially constructed,
culturally constructed or that there's
just,
or that they're just a personal whim,
which by the way,
it's exactly what's written into the
policies surrounding bill [inaudible].
Then you come out and make that case
publicly and see how well it stands up
and I know how well it'll stand up
because that kind of thinking was
defeated in the scientific realm back in
the 1960s in the universities and what
that meant was that the radicals who
want it to keep promoting precisely that
kind of view just circumvented the
entire scientific process and started to
implement their demands for their
particular viewpoint.
From a practical policy,
administrative and legislative
perspective,
knowing full well that they had lost
100% on the empirical and the scientific
front,
and now what they do instead is
criticized the scientific endeavor
itself because it failed to produce the
results that they assumed would be the
case.
So there's plenty that's rotten in the
state of Denmark and I'm embarrassed to
state that a tremendous amount of that
stems from the universities and they're
in bad shape.
Do not send your children to the
humanities,
right?
They're corrupt.
They will.
They won't learn to think because the
postmodernists don't believe in
thinking.
They won't learn logic because the
postmodernist believe that logic is one
of the tools that the oppressive
patriarchy uses to sustain its
oppressive patriarchy
or oppressive patriarchal nature.
They won't learn to write well.
That's because writing,
teaching people to write takes a
tremendous amount of effort and perhaps
they're not so much interested in
teaching people to formulate their own
thoughts precisely and carefully as they
are interested in producing cult like
clones to go out and do their activist
work,
which is precisely what they stayed on
their websites.
So,
you know,
things are not so pretty and,
and it's very embarrassing as a member
of the academy and to come before a
group of,
uh,
of public citizens and say you've been
betrayed by your institutions of higher
learning.
It's sad,
it's sad and it's not good.
And you know,
you think,
well it's just the university,
it's just an ivory tower.
It's like,
think again man.
What happens in the universities happens
everywhere five years later.
So it's no mere ivory tower issue.
So,
okay.
So a couple of weeks ago,
a couple of months ago I did this
lecture and Vancouver called the left
wing case for free speech because you
can actually make a left wing case for
free speech pretty easily.
Right?
It's like,
obviously some people have more
influence in authority than others and
just as obviously it's harder for the
people with less influence and authority
to make their case known.
So clearly they need to be able to make
their case.
So that's the left wing case for free
speech.
It's fairly straight forward.
I thought it needed to be made because
especially on the radical left,
people seem to have forgotten that free
speech was actually there.
Most what welcome friend and and enabled
them to do whatever good things they did
manage to do over the last hundred
years.
But I made a left wing case and so that
was easy and reasonably entertaining and
you can watch that on youtube if you
want.
And so tonight what I thought I'd do as
a counterpart to that is lay out what I
believe might be some tenants for a
viable 21st century conservatism.
And these are ideas that I'm playing
with.
So I'm going to,
I wrote down about 12 of them.
I don't know if we'll get through all of
them,
but we can,
we can start with a few and this is what
the Conservatives could be selling to
the public.
Now what seems to me to be happening
instead at the moment is as Kathleen
Wynne flames out,
not nearly fast enough in my opinion.
Yeah.
The attitude among conservatives that
the provincial party seems to be
something,
well let's just go like go,
let's go cluster in a corner and not do
anything too stupid because maybe she'll
burn yourself out so badly that we'll
just win the next election and we won't
have to,
you know,
do anything that will put us at risk.
And I'm not being cynical about that.
I can understand the utility of that
policy.
Although I think it's a bad policy and I
think it's a bad policy because there
are some things that seriously need to
be said about Kathleen Wynne and her
government.
And I could tell you one noble aim for
the provincial conservatives for the
next election would be to decimate the
provincial liberals.
Not One should be left.
What's,
what's your popularity at right now?
Under 10% if she had a shred of
integrity,
she would already resigned.
So anyways,
there is a goal for the conservatives,
no liberal sitting after the 2018
election that would send a message to
the social justice warrior types.
It would also send a message to the
centrists who should actually be
occupying the positions of power and the
Liberal Party that if you allow yourself
to be taken over by a radical fringe,
you're going to get decimated at the
Poles.
So you know that might be an exciting
message to sell.
Young people get out there and knock on
some doors.
See if you can take the social justice
warriors out at the top before,
before they do more damage than they've
already done.
She's got another year to do plenty of
damage and you can be sure that she's
going to do plenty more damage in that
year.
So,
okay,
what else?
Here's some things you might think about
if you're a conservative,
these things have become,
what would you say?
People are afraid to say them.
Here's the first one.
The fundamental assumptions of Western
civilization are valid.
How about that?
You know,
it's not
you,
it's an accident.
Oh,
here's how you find out.
Okay,
which countries do people want to move
away from?
Hey,
not ours.
Which countries do people wanting to
move two hours?
Guess what?
They work better.
And it's not because we went around the
world stealing everything we could get
her hands on.
It's because we got certain fundamental
assumptions.
Right.
Thank God for that.
After thousands and thousands of years
of trying and because of that,
we've managed to establish a set of
civilizations that are shining lights in
the world.
You know?
No,
you can be pretty damn filthy and still
be a shining light in this world,
right?
Because if you look around the world at
the state of governance in most places,
it's like the most pathological corrupt
and vicious thugs rule.
And to stand out as an illuminated light
against that background is it so
difficult?
But nonetheless,
you know,
we're as good as its got and unless we
can come up with something better,
we should be very careful about messing
around with that.
So why don't we start with the
assumption that we're doing something
right.
One of the things we're doing right,
for example,
is that we actually value the
individual,
right?
The individual has intrinsic value in
western societies.
Do you know how long it took people to
formulate that as an idea?
And how unlikely that idea is that poor
you,
you don't useless,
powerless you with all your damn fault.
You're actually worth something.
You're worth something to the point that
the law has to respect you.
God,
we don't want to abandon that for some
halfway did collectivism,
which we're doing as rapidly as possible
because one of the things that
characterizes the radical left types is
they don't give a damn about you as an
individual or about individuals at all.
You're black or you're white or you're
Latino or you're transsexual,
you're homosexual,
whatever.
You're a group,
you're a member of a group.
And the only thing that matters is the
group.
Well,
I can tell you if the only thing that
matters is the group,
you bloody well don't matter very much.
And then you got to ask yourself just
exactly what sort of people are trying
to set things up.
So it is that the individual doesn't
matter very much.
Well,
it's the sort of people to whom the
individual doesn't matter very much.
And I might suggest that you don't elect
them and that when they attempt to take
power that you do everything you can to
stop.
No.
Okay.
So that's assumption number one,
the assumption number two,
peaceful social being is preferable to
isolation and to war in consequence at
justly and rightly demand.
Some sacrifice of individual impulse.
An idiosyncrasy.
Okay,
so you want to live alone in the bush,
you're going to starve to death and
beat.
And by black flies,
it's not a good solution,
okay?
So you have to cooperate with other
people.
And that means you can't get to be your
whimsical self 100% of the time.
It means that most of you has to be
sacrificed so that you can be
approximately like everyone else.
Now,
that's a real sacrifice.
It's,
it's a sacrifice of,
of,
it might even be a sacrifice of some of
the unique qualities that everyone needs
from you,
socialization costs.
But the advantage of it is while we get
to exist,
look,
we can all sit together in this hall and
no one has their hands around each
other's throats.
And we're talking about serious things.
Okay,
man,
that's worth something and what it's
worth and parties.
You don't get to be whatever
spectacularly colored creature you want
to be all the time.
You have to do what you can to be normal
and predictable and it's not like normal
and predictable is the highest virtue
because it's not.
And then being more than normal and
being and being unique and creative and
contributing in that way is
extraordinarily important.
But the fundamental point is is that
social being requires the sacrifice of a
certain amount of individual
idiosyncrasies and that's a
fundamentally conservative claim.
It's like you should be,
you should do what everyone else does
unless you have a really good reason to
vary.
It's a good rule.
It's like you do what people have done
throughout time.
You grow up,
you find a partner,
you establish a stable relationship,
you get a job,
you make yourself useful.
You have some children,
you do something productive and
interesting with your spare time and you
try to act like a respectable human
being.
That's what you do.
That's a conservative ethos.
And if you're,
if you have something spectacular about
you that needs to be revealed to the
world,
then break some rules,
man,
go right ahead.
I'm dead serious about that.
But most of the time he had don't.
And even if you happen to be a special
person and you might be,
90% of you still isn't special.
So most of the time you're still going
to be following the rules and the rules
aren't there to oh press.
They're there to keep us at,
they're there to keep us away from each
other's throats because human beings are
very warlike and we're very competitive
and we're very aggressive.
And if we are fortunate enough to have
woven together a social fabric that
basically renders us peaceful and
cooperative,
we should try disrupting that at our
great peril.
Because the general rule for human
existence,
throat the centuries has been per moyle
and war and we don't have that here.
And so thank God for that and it's worth
a bit of a sacrifice.
Next.
Equality,
equity,
that's worse,
right?
Equity means equality of outcome.
It means that every single organization
has 50% women and 50% men.
It doesn't matter whether the men and
women differ in their intrinsic
preferences,
which by the way they do the scientific
literature on that is completely clear.
It was established by the early nineties
it was established in the Scandinavian
countries where they've done most to
flatten out the socioeconomic
differential saved between men and women
didn't get rid of the differences
between men and women.
In fact,
they became exaggerated.
The biggest personality differences in
the world between men and women are in
Scandinavia.
Just as the biggest differences in
interests between men and women are in
Scandinavia.
Because when you get rid of the socio
cultural differences between men and
women,
the biological differences don't
disappear.
They maximize.
How else could it be?
And as I said,
the literature on that is clear.
And the way that the postmodernist
radicals react to that is by criticizing
the scientific method itself on their
computers,
which only work of course,
because of the scientific method
actually right?
Works.
So
you hear the Egalitarian Clarion call
everywhere.
Everything should be equal.
Everything should be equally
distributed.
We should strive for equity.
It's like wrong,
especially if you're a conservative,
wrong.
What we want are just hierarchies of
competence.
Not everyone's a neurosurgeon.
You know,
if your father has a brain tumor,
you probably want a hierarchy of
competence for neurosurgeons so you can
pick the one that's the best so that he
might not die.
That's what a hierarchy of competence is
for.
For the postmodernist,
there's no hierarchy that isn't based on
power while because they think the world
runs on power and that's why they're
willing to use power to get what they
want because it's the only thing they
believe in,
but a valid hierarchy of competence.
It's God.
We need those things,
man.
We need the best plumbers.
We need the best contractors.
We need the best.
We knew we need the best carpenters,
we need the best lecturers.
There has to be a hierarchy of quality
now,
not only so that we know who the best
are and to reward them properly,
but so that we can reward them so they
keep being the best.
It's like,
you know,
if,
if you have a great educator,
if you have a great leader,
if you have a great thinker,
you want to reward them.
So they keep thinking and they keep
educating so they can tell you
something.
It's not a reward for their intrinsic
being.
It's a calculated move on your part to
suck everything out of them.
That's valuable as fast as you can.
That's what a hierarchy of competence
is.
Four.
And the idea is that hierarchies of
competence don't exist is,
it's so cynical.
It's such a pathologically cynical idea
and it's actually quite patently untrue.
Because here's an interesting tidbit
from the psychological literature.
Let's say you want to determine what the
best predictors are for lifetime success
in a Western society.
Well,
what would you hope for?
How about intelligence?
There would be a good one.
Let's hope this smart people occupy more
positions of complexity,
right?
Because they're smarter.
What do you want it any other way?
Okay.
And then so,
and that's great.
The number one predictor of
accomplishment in western societies is
intelligence.
So that means the system works.
What's the number two predictor?
Conscientiousness?
Well,
what's that?
It's a trademark or for hard work.
So who co who gets ahead?
Smart people who work hard.
Now that doesn't account for every bit
of the difference between people in
terms of their hierarchical structure.
Because hierarchies aren't perfect.
They're corrupt.
People get to the top sometimes because
there's psychopathic,
although believe me,
a hell of a lot less than you think
because a psychopath has to keep moving
from place to place because once he
reveals himself as deceitful and
untrustworthy,
he has to go find new suckers to fleece.
So the idea that you know,
there's no distinction between a CEO and
a psychopath.
It's like that's only made by someone
who a knows nothing about psychopaths
be,
knows nothing about ceos.
And C has something fundamental against
the entire capitalist structure because
it's simply not true.
Corrupt,
sometimes greedy,
sometimes shortsighted,
sometimes running companies that are
doing their best to auger themselves
into the ground.
And so,
you know,
it's bad people running a dying
organization.
But generally speaking,
it's not the case.
Our hierarchies of competence are
reasonably functional.
And not only are they functional,
they're valuable.
We need to know who the competent people
are and we need to reward them.
And even more importantly,
we need to tell young people,
hey,
there's some hierarchies of competence
out there,
like a thousand of them.
Go be a plumber man,
but be a good one.
You know,
being honest,
one B,
I had a plumber once,
you know it was the night,
it was the night before we were putting
drywall in our house.
We were redoing a house and he had put
in all the plastic piping,
you know,
and I was going to test the joints,
the,
they're supposed to be glued together
with his pipe glue,
right.
And I said,
I told him I had to test the joints and
he said,
well you don't have to test my joints.
They never leak.
And I thought,
yeah,
that's okay.
How about if I test them?
So I went up on the third floor and
filled the pipes with water,
capping them in the basement like you're
supposed to.
Like half an hour later I had two inches
of water in the basement.
There were 30 leaking joints.
And that was the night before the
drywallers were supposed to show up so
well.
So he wasn't particularly competent.
That's the point of that story.
But even more so,
he had put a bunch of the plastic pipe
outside where the drywall would be,
so it would have been sticking through
the wall.
So I spent a frenetic night,
you know,
sewing three plastic pipe and re gluing
joints so that my,
well,
so that the drywallers could come in.
What's the point?
If you're going to be a plumber,
man,
be a good plumber because otherwise all
you do is go out there and cause
trouble.
And we don't need people to cause more
We need people to solve problems,
you know?
And so you can be a tradesman and you
can be,
can make a lot of money as a trades
person.
It's a bloody reliable,
honorable,
uh,
forthright,
productive way of making a living.
And there is a hell of a lot of
difference between a working man who
knows what he's doing and one who
doesn't,
both in terms of skill and ethics.
Right.
And you work with someone who knows what
they're doing,
it's a bloody pleasure.
They tell you what they're gonna do.
They tell you how much it will cost,
they go and do it.
It works,
and you pay them perfect.
Everyone's happy.
And that's what happens when you have
genuine hierarchies of competence and so
you to,
you listen to these panderers of
egalitarianism,
gell egalitarianism,
inequity,
and they fail to recognize completely
that there are differences in ranked
between people.
It's not such a terrible thing,
man.
Maybe you wouldn't be a great lawyer
like it's certainly possible.
Most people aren't.
But that doesn't mean there isn't
something you could be great at.
There's lots of hierarchies to attempt
to climb and if he failed in one,
go try in another.
But the point is,
you're still trying to aim for the top
and what the hell are you going to do if
you don't try to aim for the top,
you know,
flap about uselessly and whine about
your life.
It's not helpful.
It'll just make you miserable.
You're not reliable to anyone.
You can't help out in a crisis.
It's like,
so you tell young people,
and this is another message for
conservatives,
like,
I don't care why you're going to do,
but go out there and make something of
yourself for God's sake.
Be An honest person and work and get to
the top of whatever it is that you want
to get to the top of,
you know,
and,
and stand up for yourself like a
respectable human being and be a bit of
a light on the world instead of a
blight.
You know,
and you can tell young people that and
they haven't been told that by anyone
now.
And so the young men are so hungry for
that,
that it's,
it's painful to watch.
They're so relieved when funding was,
someone finally comes up and says,
hey,
you know,
you,
you get your act together bit discipline
yourself.
See if you can learn to tell the truth.
Concentrate on something for a year or
two.
You could be a bloody world beater.
They think freely.
That's possible.
Wow.
That would be,
that would be interesting.
That might make life or life worth
living.
It's like,
yeah,
it might.
So why don't you go do it now?
It's what the damn universities,
we're supposed to be teaching people and
they've forgotten that.
I went to Harvard month ago,
month and a half.
You used to teach there and I talked to
a bunch of students,
you know,
and I told them it's not easy to get
into Harvard.
You know,
like you're a Valedictorian if you're at
Harvard and not only are you a
Valedictorian,
you're way better than most people at at
least two other things.
Or you don't get in.
It's so like it's,
I don't know what the acceptance rate is
like 5% and believe me,
not everybody applies.
So it's a very selective school.
And so why am I saying now it's like
these are high quality kids.
So I told them what I just told you.
It's like here you are at Harvard.
It's like get yourself educated man.
Read some books,
learn to talk,
learn to think,
make yourself into something,
get the hell out there and make the
world that put you here happy that you
were put there in that great
institution.
You know?
And they came up to me afterwards and
said,
God,
I wish someone would have told us that
when we were in our first year.
It's like,
Jesus,
why didn't someone tell them math for
God's sake?
It's supposed to be the greatest
university in the world is it's so
difficult to figure that out.
Well,
it is.
If that is what you want to have happen
in the university,
you want to make cringing Melk sops who
whine about being victims while they're
going to ivy league institutions.
Jesus
pathetic.
Here's an old idea from Carl Young.
I really liked this idea.
It's a rough one,
man.
It's like a psychotherapeutic scalpel.
Let's say someone's doing something to
you.
You don't understand it's producing
nothing but misery has an outcome.
It's like,
what the hell is your motivation?
They won't tell you.
Maybe they don't know.
So Carl Jung's advice was look at the
outcome and in further motivation.
Okay,
so you produce a generation of students
privileged beyond belief in comparison
to the rest of like struggling humanity
in all of history.
You put them in Ivy League schools and
they come out thinking that they're
members of an oppressed group and
victims.
It's like,
well,
why would you,
why would anyone,
why would that happen?
And the answer is,
well,
that's what the people who taught them
wanted to turn them into and then you
might think,
well,
did they do that because they cared for
them?
It seems bloody unlikely to me.
You take this great raw material,
right?
I mean it's taken a lot of work to make
an institution like the University of
Toronto are like Harvard.
We'd been working on that for thousands
of years and you invite people in,
you,
thank God we selected you so carefully
because we think you could be a world
beater.
And then what we do is we don't teach
you how to think.
We don't teach you how to speak.
We don't get you to read great books and
we convince you that you're a victim and
that your culture is corrupt.
It's like,
great.
Well those people are no friends of
those institutions.
I can tell you that.
And they're even less friends of those
students.
So hierarchies are cough,
competence are desirable and they should
be promoted.
So none of this idiot,
egalitarian equity,
it's not good for anyone.
First of all,
it's impossible.
Second,
it would be murderous to impose,
but third,
even if it succeeded,
it would fail as fast as it succeeded.
That would be how fast it would fail.
Why would you strive for anything if
there was no opt to strive for?
If everything's flat and equal,
well when you're starving or dying,
then everyone's equal.
And believe me,
the egalitarian,
the eye,
he galatarian totalitarians who
dominated the 20th century knew
perfectly well how to make people equal
and they made them equal in ghoulag work
camps and in starvation.
And I'm sure we could attain that if we
wanted to.
So all right,
next borders are reasonable.
How about that?
Okay,
the law is the border that stops someone
from stealing your
laptop.
And if it's an apple laptop,
while it's the sort of laptop that has
social justice warrior would carry and
then the social justice warrior is going
to be very irritated if you happen to
purloin their laptop.
And then you might point out to them,
you know,
it's a border that protects from having
that thing taken and they say,
well,
the border should be open.
It's okay man.
No problem that you hand over that
laptop right now and everything else you
own too.
If you don't like borders and you can
get rid of the damn walls in your house
and you don't need doors on your bedroom
either and we can keep an eye on you
whenever we want and so much for
borders.
One of the things that really differs
between liberals and conservatives
between the left and the right is the
right is in the right,
likes tight borders between things.
It's part of being conscientious at
every level,
conceptually,
sexually,
familiarly provincially,
nationally.
The right says,
look,
let's keep,
let's keep the borders between things
pretty distinct.
And the left says,
yeah,
maybe not because some of those borders
are in the wrong place and a little bit
more free flow of information wouldn't
be a bad thing.
And the thing is,
they're right,
but so are the Conservatives and that's
why you have to talk.
It's like,
well,
we've got some borders.
That's a good thing.
Maybe some of them need to be moved
around a little bit.
And that's what the political dialogue
is for.
But that doesn't mean that borders
themselves are a bad idea.
There are a great idea because without
borders,
everything mashes into the same
untenable state of undifferentiated
chaos and you can't live in that.
And so the people who are trying to tear
down the borders conceptually,
politically,
and practically what they want is the
chaos that that would bring.
The either want that or they're too
foolish to know that their pursuits will
produce that.
So let's,
let's,
let's be a little bit clear that if you
stand up and say,
yeah,
borders,
they're okay,
they've got their problems,
but they're okay.
That doesn't make you,
uh,
a bigot beyond redemption.
It just makes you someone with some
sense and it's actually okay to be
someone with some sense
limits on immigration are also
reasonable.
Well,
we need to figure out what those limits
are and that's what the bloody political
dialogue is for.
But the fact that it should be limited
to some degree is also reasonable.
Otherwise,
why not just open the borders and let
everybody come in?
Well,
the reason you don't do that,
it's because a complex system cannot
tolerate extensive transformation over
too short a period of time.
Now you want immigrants to come in,
especially if they're the sorts of
immigrants who are likely to contribute
properly to the success of your polity.
And lots of immigrants do that.
I mean,
I think the vast majority,
for example,
of entrepreneurs in the United States
come from the Indian subcontinent.
So great in Ho bring them over.
They're highly educated,
they're extraordinarily productive.
They make lots of new businesses and
then they pump money like back,
like mad back in India.
Good deal.
But that doesn't mean that we have,
we have,
uh,
our arms are open to everyone
immigration policy because it's complete
rubbish.
All that means is you're not thinking
about it.
So when it,
here's a coded to that for
conservatives,
here's something I've been thinking
about this a lot lately.
It should not be assumed that citizens
of societies that have not evolved
functional individual rights predicated
Paulie.
These will hold values in keeping with
such polities.
So we could say,
look,
there are a lot of countries in the
world that are not governed well,
the vast majority of them,
right?
And they'd be not governed well forever.
And to me that means that there's
something wrong with the values that are
held collectively by the people who've
established those polarities.
Well,
you shouldn't be naive and assume that
merely because you moved them to a new
country,
they're going to let their innate
democratic longings flourish.
It doesn't work that way.
So if you stand up and say,
look,
you know,
let's be a little cautious.
Let's make sure that we don't transform
our society so rapidly that we lose what
we have.
Let's be careful about that.
That doesn't mean that you're a morally
reprehensible demon.
It just means that you're conservative
and it's a reasonable position to hold.
So there's no sense in Nepal dicing to
it for it.
Now,
that doesn't mean you get to like hide
your bigotry under a mask of moral
virtue.
You know the discrimination issue is
quite clear as far as I'm concerned.
So that's associated with bigotry.
If you have two people who are applying
for a job,
you should pick the one that's most
qualified and not pay any attention to
any of the other attributes of the
person that have nothing to do with the
job.
Okay.
Right.
I think basically,
I think we figured that out in about
1965 now we're not doing it perfectly,
you know,
but it's not that much later than 1965
and our society particularly in Canada
is pretty damn open.
You can come in here and if you work
hard and if you're fortunate you don't
get sick and God smiles on you so to
speak,
you can be successful.
There's still prejudice,
unreasonable prejudice and
discrimination,
but our society is not as the radical
egalitarian equity promoters have it
structurally racist,
bigoted,
and misogynistic.
No,
not only that.
Just so you know,
there is a review.
There was a recent review published and
I mean recent 2017 looking at that damn
literature on unconscious bias and I
knew the literature to begin with,
there is no evidence that unconscious
bias can be measured properly,
not reliably.
There's also no evidence whatsoever that
if you do measure it and you can't very
well that it does any better job of
predicting actual say bias and,
and,
and uh,
prejudice.
Then just tests of attitude.
So the notion that our culture is
somehow structurally misogynistic and
racist and the reason for that is
because of the unconscious bias of the
monsters who are running it is,
is,
well maybe it's not wrong,
but I can tell you one thing about it.
It is not a scientifically justifiable
proposition and that's what it's being
passed off as.
And I placed that firmly at the feet of
the social psychologists with social
psychology happens to be a fairly
corrupt,
disciplined by the way.
And the people who invented
the implicit association test,
which measures unconscious bias because
they have not come out publicly to the
degree that they should have been said
are test,
which was for experimental purposes,
is being misused politically.
You know your damn judges now because of
federal five feet,
half to undergo mandatory unconscious
bias retraining before they can sit on
the bench.
And so you don't think that's political
reeducation is because you're not paying
attention and there's zero evidence that
it does what it's supposed to.
And I would also recommend to all of
you,
if you happen to be in a workplace that
introduces diversity training or
unconscious bias training as a mandatory
requirement,
you tell them and knows it,
no uncertain terms,
that you are not participating in a
process that deems you bigoted and
misogynistic without evidence of that
being the case.
And if you trot off to the training,
then you've just agreed that that's who
you are.
And believe me,
once you've agreed to that man,
you'll be agreeing to take a bunch of
things you don't want to agree soon
afterwards.
So it's time just to put a stop to that.
Enough of that,
none of that unconscious bias retreading
especially not the mandatory type.
People should be paid so that they are
able and willing to perform socially
useful and desirable duties.
Okay,
so the radical leftists,
they react to me this way.
They say,
well,
you hold a position of privilege and
power and I think first you don't know a
goddamn thing about me and you have no
idea how I got to my position of
privilege and power and it was no
birthright.
I can tell you that I was a small,
like thick glassed intellectual
[inaudible].
What do you call that Athletic Child?
You'd always a year younger than my
peers.
I suffered plenty of,
what would you say?
Trouble for my loud mouth and my
intellect when I was growing up.
You know,
I had my struggles.
I'm not complaining about it.
The point is is that you can't attribute
privileged to a class of people and no
one,
you can't attribute power to people who
happened to occupy a position of
competence and authority either.
There's some possibility that they
occupied that because they worked hard
and were fortunate.
Let's not forget about that and had some
good social support and didn't have some
horrible disease,
thank God.
But you can't just make the case that
the position is there as a reward.
It's not there as far as a reward at
all.
It's there as a consequence of the
person offering something valuable to
those who want to pay for it.
And the reason you pay for them isn't to
reward them.
It isn't so that you give them a pat on
the back and say,
well,
you're a good person and you know you
deserve this position.
It's because you're saying to them,
produce.
We find what you're producing a value.
And so we're going to give you what you
need in order to be motivated to keep
doing it.
But it's not because we like cue.
It's not because we re we respect your
rights.
It has nothing to do with equity.
It's,
we're trying to get every God damn thing
we can from you as fast as possible and
we're going to pay you to do.
And so people deserve their damn pay.
And the reason they deserve it isn't
because it's a reward.
It's because that's how you get
productive people to do things that are
difficult and time consuming.
And that perhaps they wouldn't do on
their own accord to continue doing them
so you can benefit from it.
So the whole notion that,
you know,
we're awarding positions of privilege,
too,
oppressive patriarchal types,
it's like we just have to get rid of
that.
Enough of that.
That's,
that's nonsense.
It's absolute nonsense.
And the other thing too is,
you know,
it's only been 30 40 years,
50 years since women had reliable birth
control.
Right?
And we're able to enter the workforce on
Mohs.
I'll tell you,
man,
we've produced a cultural revolution in
like 50 years.
Women are everywhere.
It's like how bloody fast do you expect
something like that to go?
And what makes you think that pushing it
really hard,
he's going to make it go any better.
I mean,
as far as I can tell,
we manage that transition about as well
as we possibly could have.
We're still sorting out the details,
but the fact that you know this is
coming very rapidly down the pipes.
The fact that half of our corporate
board members are women is not
indicative of the fact that we live in
an unconsciously biased,
misogynistic,
patriarchal society.
Sorry,
wrong,
not correct and so we shouldn't be
allowing,
and this is happening very,
very rapidly and you can be sure
Kathleen Wynne is going to be putting
this in as policies rapidly as she
possibly can.
These equity demands to ensure that
there's proportional representation of
every gender,
every sex,
every race,
every ethnicity at every level of every
organization.
It's like,
really,
we're going to do that by governmental
Fiat.
It's like,
that's not as society I want to live in.
I tell you and I can,
I can I quite certain that if you lived
in that society for any length of time,
you'd learn very rapidly that it isn't a
society that you'd want to be part of.
Either
citizens have the inalienable right to
benefit from the results of their own
owners labor.
That's a good one.
Yes,
that's a conservative truism.
You know why,
what isn't because you,
because you're good,
harder than you want them to have money.
It's because they'll work if you let
them benefit from the work and you want
them to work because if they work then
they do things that you need.
It's as simple as that.
It's self interest and it's the right
kind of self interest.
So if you work hard,
it's like great.
Have your money.
You know,
and you hear people all the time talking
about how corrupt our society is and how
the 1% you know,
occupies this pinnacle position.
You know,
the 1% turns over pretty damn fast just
so you know it.
So you have about a 10% chance of
spending at least one year in the top 1%
chance during your life.
I think that's right.
I think it's 10% it might be higher than
that,
but it's fast.
It's the 1% is stable as a phenomenon,
but it turns over very rapidly in terms
of who occupies it and it's the same in
every society.
The wealth is always distributed
inequitably.
It's a natural law.
You can look it up.
It,
it was discovered by a guy named Wilfred
Prieto back in the late 18 hundreds
goods tend to diminish to distribute
inequitably.
It can be a problem,
but it doesn't mean that there's
something fundamentally corrupt about
the social structure that's driving it
in that direction.
Like you,
you don't want some filthy rich geniuses
lying around like maybe you do.
Let me look at what he learned.
Musk is doing for God's sake.
Maybe he should have 10 times as much
money as he has.
He's going to launch a rocket every five
days to Mars in the next 10 years,
right?
He wants to wipe out fossil fuel cars
and he might do it.
He wants to revolutionize the
transportation system and he might do
it.
He wants to put us on the damn solar
grid with his new batteries and he might
do it.
It's like,
oh no,
he has a couple of billion dollars.
Well God only knows what he's going to
produce with that.
It's like,
so obviously there's going to be some
corrupt,
there's to be some corrupt rich
plutocrats who do nothing but smoke
cigars and snort cocaine.
They're not gonna live very long
anyways.
But there's lots of people out there who
have the money they have because they
would really like to do interesting and
creative things with it.
Not because they're interested in
gathering more,
you know,
paper money to stuff in their mattress
and,
and to like to feel the smooth,
the smooth delight of gold coins between
their fingers before they go to bed.
Like what kind of attitude is that
towards people who've made their
fortune?
You know,
you think that about Steve Jobs,
you think that about Bill Gates.
I mean,
good God,
I don't know how those people may,
lot of money,
but man,
thank God they were around,
you know,
they've given us some tools that are
just absolutely unbelievable.
So,
you know,
maybe we could leave the jealousy of the
successful behind for a while and notice
now and then that some of the people who
got to where they are actually deserve
to get to where they are and we should
be thankful that they exist.
That would be nice.
A little gratitude and that's a good
conservative value to,
it is more noble to teach young people
about responsibilities then about
rights.
That's a good conservative message.
It's like you have his son,
you know,
or you have a daughter and you say,
bloody well grow up.
Stand on your own two feet and make
something of yourself right so that I
can be proud of you when you come over.
And so that may be your useful in a
crisis.
It's like pick up your damn load and
Mandy and shoulder it and do something
useful and,
and forget about your damn rights for
awhile.
You can think about what it is that you
should be doing to benefit yourself and
your family and society and you'll find
some purpose in your life because of
that.
And so well that's a counter position to
the perpetrators of the endless rights
buffet,
right?
Well as long as we give you enough
rights,
you're going to be what?
Free.
You're going to be happy.
It's like,
yeah,
sure you'll drown in a sea of chaos and
that's what's happening to people now
too.
So and that's why young people are so
hungry to have someone talk to them
about responsibilities.
Here's another one.
Radical change should be viewed with
suspicion,
particularly in a time of radical
change.
Okay.
There's never been a time in the history
of the world where things are changing
as fast as they are now and not only are
they changing fast,
the rate at which they're changing is
increasing.
Like we're moving fast forward at such a
rate that it's unbelievable.
You can't even keep up.
I don't care what discipline you're in.
It's like it's not so bad to have some
people putting their feet in the ground
are digging their heels in and say,
look,
we got a lot to swallow already.
We got a lot to chew on and Digest.
Let's not muck about with everything
that's worked so far,
what has worked.
It's not such a bad idea for people to
have long term families,
right?
We could say,
let's try to support the family.
We can even say,
let's try to support the traditional
family.
Why?
Well,
maybe boys and girls need role models of
each sex.
I know that's a terrible thing to say,
but it is possible.
It's certainly the case too,
that intact two parent families have
children that thrive more than broken
families and broken families or a
catastrophe or for everyone.
Now you might say,
well,
I shouldn't stay with someone that I
don't get along with,
and it's like,
yeah,
fair enough.
Except that there's no one that you're
ever going to find to stay with it.
You're going to get along with all of
the time,
especially in your shotty condition,
and so you're lucky that anybody,
oh,
you're lucky that anybody will put up
with you for a week,
much less your whole life.
It's like the,
the point of marriage is to tough it out
and you don't tough it out for your
happiness.
That's not what you're in there for.
Your tough it out so that you have
someone to tie the rope of your life
together with them.
You have a chance to tie the rope of
your life together with the rope of
someone else's life and to make it
strong and to make a place the children
can have some security and some
encouragement and thereby contribute to
the future and pay for the miracle of
your birth and your own raising.
That's why you get married.
And there's no reason that conservatives
can't stand up and say,
look,
we're willing to tolerate alternative
family arrangements.
But when you start making the claim that
the traditional family unit is just
another construct and that it's not
something fundamental to our polity,
it's like that's,
you've taken your damn argument too far.
First of all,
you have no evidence whatsoever for that
claim and there's plenty of counter
evidence.
So you know,
one of the things the postmodernists
basically say us,
you know,
every time you stand up for something,
you're also standing against something.
It's like,
yeah,
that's true.
But that doesn't mean that you shouldn't
stand up for things.
And I think if we,
if we,
if there is something that conservatives
could agree on that we could stand up
for,
it's the nuclear family now.
Exactly how that's gonna play out.
I don't exactly know,
but it's nothing too,
it's not anything to be ashamed of to
say,
well it kind of looks like that
structures work quite well for the
entire duration of mankind and so maybe
we mess with it at our peril.
Here's another one.
The government,
local and distant should leave people to
their own devices as much as possible.
Why?
Well,
part of it's just humility.
It's like I'd rather that there was a
million of you out there making own
stupid mistakes so that maybe a thousand
of you can get it right then for one of
you to impose their view on everyone and
risk getting it catastrophical he wrong
for everyone at the same time.
And that's really the alternative.
Like if you're a social scientist,
like I mean an actual scientist,
I don't mean a bloody idiot log.
One of the things that you learned very
rapidly.
As you know,
you do a simple experiment.
You think you're going to predict some
element of human behavior,
you,
so here's my hypothesis.
I'm going to put people in this
experimental situation and this is what
they're going to do,
and then you run the experiment and they
don't do that.
They do something completely different.
You find out that even though what you
have them do is really simple,
you don't have a clue what they're up
to,
and that's just a tiny little controlled
experiment about one little tiny thing
and you're wrong.
It's like
one of the great advantages to
conservative philosophy is that it's
humble.
It's humble from,
from the perspective of social
experimentation.
It's like it's not like everything's
great and we should just continue going
the way we're going.
It's like,
well,
everything isn't as broken as it might
be and I'm kind of stupid and blind and
all I have is a bat and probably hitting
it isn't going to make it any better.
All do is shatter it and so the
conservative says it's working,
be quiet,
sneak away.
Maybe it will keep working and that's a
perfectly reasonable perspective.
Now obviously sometimes things have to
change,
but the conservative can come up and
say,
don't be thinking that you have so much
evidence that what you're doing is right
or that it will have the outcome that
you expect it.
I'll tell you a quick story.
This was told to me by a woman named
Joan Mccord,
who was one of the world's first female
criminologist,
by the way,
a phd from temple,
University of a genius level,
genius level person.
Very tremendous integrity,
tough,
tough person.
She did a study in a place called
Somerville in the United States in
Massachusetts in the 1930s famous study,
and so here is the deal.
They'd identified a bunch of inner city
kids in rough neighborhoods and felt,
you know,
that they were more likely to be on a
criminal track,
criminal,
antisocial,
undereducated alcohol,
you know,
the whole,
the whole dismal,
wretched,
underclass phenomena thing was going on.
And so they thought,
well,
let's do an intervention.
Let's set up programs to help these kids
and see if we can see if we can change
their developmental pathway.
So
they designed to find study man and had
the kids,
I'll get the details wrong,
but I got the,
I got the story right.
Um,
they had the kids,
they made them more literate,
they educated the more they had their
parents take training courses,
they did social skills training,
like they did all sorts of things to try
to make the kids' lives turn out better.
And to top it all off because the kids
were stuck in the inner city and they
took them all out to summer camp for a
couple of weeks a year.
And so they could get away from the city
and you know,
enjoy the countryside,
have a little bit of a vacation,
a little taste of a higher quality life.
Yeah.
So great.
Everyone's thrilled with the damn
program.
The kids are having a great time at
camp.
The counselors are thrilled to
psychologists.
They think they're doing a wonderful job
with great.
It's working beautifully,
except then they did the data analysis.
Guess what happened?
The kids in the,
in their treatment group,
there was a control group,
right?
That didn't get all this special
treatment randomly assigned.
It was a very nice experiment.
The kids in the treatment group get
worse on virtually everything that was
measured worse.
Why
don't put anti social kids together in
the same camp for two weeks during the
year,
right?
Right.
Because what happens is that the bad
kids teach the slightly less bad kids to
be worse.
It's a well documented phenomenon.
That's why what happens in prisons
happens in prisons.
What we do with criminals is the worst
thing you could possibly do to criminals
if you don't want them to continue to be
criminals,
except for the fact that you keep them
in there until they're old enough,
generally speaking,
so they're less likely to engage in
criminal activity.
But what was learned from the Somerville
study was don't be so sure your good
intentions are going to produce the
results that you intend because they
probably won't and they probably won't
for reasons that you never even
imagined.
And the other one was
don't group bad kids with good kids on
the assumption that the good kids will
make the bad kids better because that
isn't what happens.
What happens is the reverse.
If you put two or three bad kids with a
bunch of good kids,
then the good kids get worse.
The bad kids don't get better.
Very well documented social science
finding,
well,
the reason I'm telling you the
Somerville story is because God who
could argue with that study,
right?
It's like these kids were poor,
they were struggling.
It's like you want to,
you want to lift them up,
you want to make their life better.
You do this wonderful,
expensive,
well motivated experiment and then you
run the damn data analysis and you find
out that there was one thing wrong with
your social intervention philosophy that
you didn't understand and you actually
made it worse.
Well,
that's a,
and so jo,
Joan Mccord,
she spent much of the rest of her life
going around telling social scientists.
When you run a social experiment,
politicians,
the same thing.
When you run a social experiment,
especially on a large number of people,
especially without their consent,
then gather the data and do the followup
study because it's highly probable that
you'll find that what you did didn't
work.
Or maybe it even worked backwards and
you'll never know that unless you do the
study.
And so what people took away from that,
the social intervention types took away
from that was whatever you do with your
social intervention policy,
don't run the study.
Right?
Right.
That was the wrong lesson,
by the way.
Okay.
And this is what I would close with for
the Conservatives.
This is a nice one.
I really like this.
We hear a lot about the sins of the west
and there are manifold because people
are corrupt and our societies are
corrupt.
But you have to think about it in terms
of relative corruption rather than
absolute corruption.
It's like,
well,
you know,
your family is not perfect,
but there are worse families compared to
the perfect family.
Your family isn't looking so good,
but compared to other families,
maybe it's not looking so bad at,
okay,
so how do we judge our political system?
Well we don't judge it by the dreamlike
ill informed,
ideologically motivated pathological
utopias of the radical left or the
radical right for that matter.
We saw what happened in the 20th
century.
When you do that,
that is a very,
very bad idea.
And you know there were tens of millions
of people that died in the 20th century
demonstrating just how bad an idea was
that was.
And you'd think we would have learned
that,
but we didn't.
What you do instead is you take a look
at your country and you think,
okay,
how is it doing compared to other
countries,
other actual real countries.
And maybe you look at a variety of
different indicators because that's what
you do.
If you're careful and if it happens to
be hovering up near the top,
then you think,
well,
it might be just the grace of God might
be just good fortune,
but it is possible that we've got
something right and that we shouldn't
muck around with it too much and that we
should have some gratitude for it
instead of assuming that the proper
comparison is whatever heaven that you
happen to be able to dream up,
that you would love to impose on other
people without their cooperation and
without their will,
and that's what the bloody social
utopians are selling us and they're
doing everything they can to implement
and institute that as rapidly as
possible.
It's like enough of that.
We've had enough of that like I,
the reason I got into this to begin with
is because I started studying
totalitarianism when I was about 13 but
I really started to study it when I was
about 22 and I spent like 15 20,000
hours reading and writing about
totalitarianism three hours a day for 15
years.
That was the first book I wrote.
It just about bloody well killed me.
It's horrible stuff.
And you know,
I was curious about what the hell had
happened,
not only not only in Nazi Germany,
but then installing this brush in Mao's
China and in the Cold War's like,
what the hell were we up to?
Why were we doing all of that?
I was trying to figure it out.
It's not a pretty sight.
Well,
a lot of that's driven by this insane
Utopian vision.
It's not a place we want to go.
We want to accept the flaws in our
system with some humility and some
desire to improve things.
But good God.
You know,
the 20th century was a dreadful
bloodbath.
It was a horrific hundred years and we
should have learned,
we should have learned arrogant utopia
turns into hell.
That's what we should have learned.
And yet we have people,
plenty arrogant,
purveying utopia left and right and
saying,
hey look,
the utopia hasn't come yet.
And the reason for that is you're a
misogynistic bigot.
And if you don't believe that,
and I can't measure it by asking you or
even know to any observable behavior on
your part,
then I'm going to infer it.
Or I'll give you an unconscious bias
test that doesn't even measure what it's
supposed to measure.
So you're a damn misogynist and a bigot
whether you know it or not,
whether you want to be or not and
whether or not the evidence suggests
that you are or not.
So no,
we're not going to sell out our society
to utopians of that sort.
And so I would say to people who want to
be conservative.
First
of all,
you have every right to be conservative
and there's nothing wrong with you for
being conservative.
And second,
it's like it's time to get the hell
organized and push back and get that 5%
of hyper educated,
resentful utopian dreamers who would
like to bring the whole God damn
civilization to its knees out of the
systems of power.
It's not the same country it was 10
years ago.
It's we need to wake up and we need to
stop this from happening.
I would say these are more practical
circumstances.
The Ontario Human Rights Commission,
that thing has to go the social justice
tribunals.
I made it
[inaudible]
that thing has to go,
we need to pay a lot more attention to
what the faculties of education or
teaching teachers because they are
transforming the elementary school and
the junior high school and high school
systems into nothing but propaganda
machines for radical postmodernists
doctrine.
And if you don't believe me,
you just go look it up on the web and
see what they're,
what they're attempting to impose.
And so that's got to stop,
right or easy.
The Ontario Institute for Studies of
Education,
that is not a good place.
They need to be held accountable for
what they're doing.
They're supposed to be studying how to
educate children more effectively and
faster and cheaper and better.
And that isn't what they're doing.
They're producing.
People have the most radical and
resentful sort to get a handle on the
minds of children as young as they
possibly can.
And that's,
that's the doctrine.
I'm not making this up.
It's actually quite intelligent if
that's what it is that you're aiming for
and that's got to,
that's got to come to a stop.
And we've,
I don't know if there's more that needs
to be done done to,
they'll whole bloody human rights
establishment has to be retooled because
it's working at counter purposes to
itself.
It was probably a mistake back in the
when it,
when was it?
It was probably a mistake to introduce
the damn bill writes into Canada to
begin with.
It was probably a legislative era that
we're paying desperately for now.
But anyways,
those are more specific things and those
are more opinions of mine so you can
take them or leave them as far as I'm
concerned.
But these 12 points that I made,
as far as I can tell,
you know,
those are reasons to be conservative and
they're not reasons to be ashamed of it.
And if you're afraid of speaking your
mind as a conservative,
well stumble a bit,
make a few mistakes,
man,
you're going to make some mistakes.
You're probably,
you know,
not as articulate as you might be in.
Believe me,
there's lots of things you need to know.
But if you start saying what you think
carefully,
people will correct you and you'll get
better at it.
And you better start doing it because
the situation that we're in,
I think it's worse than it looks.
That's how it looks to me.
So anyways,
that's all I've got to say about that.
So thank you for the invitation.
[inaudible] you gonna open
up for questions and hopefully some
answers as well.
So if anybody has
anything,
we only have one microphone so you'll
have to stand up.
I'd like you to speak loudly and clearly
so we can all hear and uh,
and also state your name and where
you're from,
separation
of church and state
churches
of Western society,
religion and Christianity.
Sure.
Yeah,
sure.
Ask An easy question.
So the question essentially was what my
opinion was about the separation of
church and state that the nature of the
separation of church and state,
given the hypothesis that our society is
grounded in a broader structure,
moral structure,
let's say that has,
uh,
something like God,
theologically predicated philosophical
basis.
It's something like that.
The first thing I would say is if you,
if,
if that is a very hard question to
answer,
and I'm doing this series in Toronto
right now on on,
it's called the psychological
significance of the biblical stories.
And it's an answer to that question,
but it's long.
It's like 40 hours,
you know,
and it's like the maps of meaning
program that that Mr Hillier was
referring to before.
It's extraordinarily complicated and I
mean I think the right approach to that
is to say something like that.
Something like there are things that are
Caesar's and there are things that are
God's and you should keep those things
apart.
That's worked in the West.
Now the problem without our answer is it
doesn't precisely describe the proper
interrelationship between the two,
but I don't think that's actually a
political issue.
I think that the way that that's
properly bridged is through the ethic of
the individual is like your religious
belief should be of the sword that
guides you to be an honest,
decent,
productive,
respectable person who's aiming at the
good.
And then if you do that,
then the political issues,
we'll take care of themselves.
Not magically,
but because we'll organize ourselves
politically as that sort of people and
do the right things.
And so I think the connection between
the church and the state is through the
individual.
That's how it should work.
And I think that's why it's kind of
worked in the West,
you know,
getting that church state separation
thing right.
That's really difficult.
It's not good when they collapsed into
one another because you instantly get
the rise of totalitarian theocracy and
we all know how much fun they are.
So yeah,
I'll just listen to understand what
we're going to do just to make this
work.
If you do have a question,
why don't you come up to the front all
hand over the microphone to you and then
you can,
uh,
everybody can hear the question clearly.
I,
and then we'll pass the microphone back.
Okay.
I'm Brian Oil Oil Zalewski still people,
you're going to warn you.
I took a psychology 100 big deal.
[inaudible]
conceded my Eczema,
the crowd.
And I have a black Somali Mosley
director who's had a call with me and
our ideals,
beliefs,
policies,
et cetera.
And if I'd known,
I would've brought up here is my guest
and he's a wonderful guy and many,
many solid talks together.
And that's probably the one thing that's
missing here tonight.
Yeah.
Well look,
there's something else I'd like to
suggest to conservatives now.
You know,
um,
I've interacted with a very diverse
range of people partly because I'm a
clinical psychologist and I've done a
lot of different things with different
people in my life.
And so,
um,
I can speak about this particular issue
with a modicum of authority.
See in Canada what's happened is that
we've left the minority immigrants to
the liberals.
How has a bad idea now,
the reason for that is because the
liberals have a more liberal immigration
policy and a lot of them are like
really,
uh,
what would you say grateful to the
Liberals often to trudeau personally.
I mean the older trudeau personally
because he opened the door and let them
in and,
and it's hard to shake that.
But here's something that's very cool
for conservatives to know.
You think you're conservative,
man,
you should go talk to immigrants.
There are so conservative they make you
look like social justice warriors,
right?
So there's a real conversation.
There's a real conversation to be had
with immigrants and minorities in
Canada.
I spent it,
sorry,
especially the immigrant minorities and
that is,
look,
we would have been a little bit more
restrictive in the past about our
immigration policies and I can
understand why that might marcus out his
enemies to you,
but one of the things you have to
understand is that the bedrock values
that I have are much closer to the
bedrock values than you that you have.
Then the people that you're voting for.
And you know the minority immigrants in
Ontario in particular are starting to
figure this out,
especially with regards to Kathleen
winds education policies because they
notice the tilt of those policies and
they notice that they're not in keeping
with,
they're often extremely conservative
traditions and so I would say the right
thing for conservatives to do is like
start telling the minority immigrants
that you're actually their friends.
Now that means to establish an
intelligent immigration policy and that
that's a very difficult thing to do and
to begin a real dialogue about that with
immigrant communities,
you know who are often,
by the way,
very interested in protecting what they
found here and not having it disrupted
in any particularly terrible way.
I mean there's,
there's you rackles everywhere,
but most of the immigrants who come
here,
if they're pretty damn happy to be here,
so the conservatives should be out there
extending a real hand.
Especially I would say especially to the
moderate Muslims.
It's a big mistake not to do that.
There's lots of moderate Muslims.
There are people who they're not in
chanted by the theocratic totalitarians
and they're looking for a way to develop
a bridge between Islam and the West.
That's no easy thing.
I'm not even sure it can be done,
but there are people of goodwill in our
country who would like to have that
happened in the conservatives could be
talking to them and extending a hand.
It's going to help on the,
on the what?
On the,
on the voting front as well.
There's no loss in it,
there's absolutely no loss.
And all you have to do is knock and say,
Hey,
those people that you're supporting,
they don't share any of your values.
Have you noticed that they'll wake up,
they'll see it,
and then they'll say,
well,
you know,
maybe we have more in common with the
traditional conservatives in Canada than
we thought.
It wouldn't be a difficult message to
get to get out there.
So,
yeah.
Oh,
I'm just going to follow up on that
comment from Brian for d for a moment.
And I think it's important to recognize
the,
the historical change in shift that has
happened with immigration in this
country over a long,
long period of time.
You know,
this country was built and developed on
immigrants to rural areas.
That's,
that's our history.
You know,
that's where all our settlement programs
were to bring new immigrants to whirl
areas.
That's fundamentally shifted in the last
number of decades.
New Immigration to this country is to
our significant urban centers.
That's where it's where it's happening.
So I just,
you know,
uh,
so walking through Carlton Place is
going to be a very different
image than walking through Toronto or
Ottawa.
Um,
so that's,
uh,
I'm,
I'm very pleased to see the number of
people that we have out here,
the diversity of age and the diversity
of people.
But um,
but we just don't have a lot of
immigrants in rural Ontario.
So,
um,
anyway,
policies like the actual concrete issues
that people may or may not differ on how
I want it to know what you thought.
Like the root causes strictly from a
psychological perspective that would
derive a lot of these predominantly
young,
like early to mid twenties,
what you bars are left people to really
be so reasonable and antiestablishment
militarize and their thinking and
essentially to have such a negative view
on the world and to see all these
problems that other people would never
notice when they have not point almost
terminal.
Uh,
just strictly and in men and women's
specifically.
Um,
strictly from like,
you know,
what,
what would derive someone you think to
think that way?
Well,
we,
we kind of know some of the answers to
that.
I don't want to make too grandiose a
claim,
but I've done some research with my
graduate students on political
correctness per say,
because we'd been interesting interested
in the personality predictors of
political belief.
It really does turn out that you vote
your personality far more than you
think.
Because like what you think is that you
look at the world and there's a
landscape of facts and you view the fact
subjectively and you derive your
conclusions.
And the thing is doesn't really work
that way because there's just too damn
many facts,
right?
And so you can't even really get an
unbiased sample of them.
What happens is that your,
your personality works as a filtering
mechanism so that certain things stand
out for you more than other things.
And so some things stand out more for
the people on the radical left.
And some things stand out for people who
are liberal in some things stand out for
people who are conservative.
And then everyone says,
well look,
I'm looking at the facts and I'm drawing
this conclusion.
It's like,
yeah,
but what you don't understand is you're
not looking at the same set of facts and
you can't even,
and that's why you have to actually
engage in dialogue with other people
because they'll expose you to their set
of facts.
And I'm not saying that facts don't
exist or that they're relativistic or
anything like that.
One of the things we found out about the
politically correct types is that
they're high and a trait called
agreeableness.
Now you might think really that isn't
what I would've guessed,
but,
but agreeableness is a maternal trait
and women are higher in agreeableness
than Matt.
And that's cross cultural.
And that difference really seems to
start manifesting itself primarily a
puberty.
And so agreeableness is likely the trait
that stops you from throwing your baby
it out the window at three in the
morning when it's speed,
when just had colac for three hours and
you haven't had any sleep and you're not
in very good shape and you just got laid
off.
It's like it's a very,
very tight bonding mechanism.
And so what happens,
it's primarily driven by what you might
describe as compassion.
Now,
compassion is great for dealing with
infants and maybe it's great for dealing
with hurt people and really elderly
people.
You know,
it's good for taking care of people who
can't take care of themselves,
but it's not a great doctrine to be
building a political system on.
And so one of the things that happens
with the more politically correct types
by temperament is that they're,
they,
they suffer from an excess of impulsive
compassion.
And they assume that if there's
inequitable distribution of anything,
that the people who are at the bottom
are all victims who should be treated
like infants.
And that everyone at the top is a
vicious snake,
like Predator.
And,
and,
and that's hard wired in some sense now
it's a very popular story.
Yeah,
of course.
Of course.
It's an,
and it's an easy story to sell and
there's some truth in it,
but some truth isn't the same as all of
the truth.
And so what you see at least in is
undifferentiated empathy.
And that is not,
that's not a virtue.
It's not a virtue.
You have to think.
You can't just feel,
you have to think,
you know,
even when you're taking care of kids,
part of what you're doing is being
compassionate.
But if you're too compassionate towards
your kids,
then you do everything for them.
And if you do everything,
everything for them,
then they grow up useless and they never
leave and they hate you and they hate
everything else too.
It's a bad idea.
And so you use compassion judiciously.
You know there's a rule if you're
working in a place like a nursing home
and the rule is to harsh rule,
do not do anything for the people that
you're taking care of that they can do
for themselves.
And so if they have to struggle to feed
themselves,
you don't buddy while intervene in feed
them,
you let them maintain their damn
independence and you have to be a hard
hearted bastard to do that.
You know,
to watch someone's struggle like that.
But you're furthering their long,
medium to longterm independence and
development.
And you do the same thing with your
children.
Treating your children like they're
endless.
Permanent victims is a very bad idea.
And I think that's part of what,
that's part of what's also being taught.
We also know that the kids who are more
likely to be rabidly politically
correct,
one of the reasons that they're more
likely to be that way is because they
were taught to be that way.
We found that even exposure to a single
lecture,
a single lecture that was associated
with the political correct,
dogmatic structure was enough to tilt
people in that direction.
So there's a temperamental proclivity
and then there's failure of education to
address that.
And then there's the exacerbation and
exaggeration by the,
by the people who are trying to produce
like activists by proxy.
You know,
one of the most appalling things I saw,
for example at mcmaster when I went to
mcmaster and got,
you know,
yelled down by profanity shouting people
who had the bloody gall to hide behind a
banner that had a hammer and sickle on
it for God's sake.
You know,
if the Nazis would have been out there
with their swastika,
there would've been held to pay.
But because it was the hammer and
sickle,
it's like,
it's okay.
There's nothing wrong with being a
communist.
It's like,
sorry about the 200 million dead people
folks.
So they're out there,
you know,
hiding behind this,
behind this banner.
Um,
none of the,
none of the people who are teaching
them,
we're out there.
They,
they bailed out of the damn discussion,
right?
Cause there were four people who were
supposed to talk with me there.
They all vanished.
They leave these student proxies to go
out there and do their dirty work.
It's really,
it's really contemptible so you can lay
a fair bit of the blame at the feet of
the people who are supposed to be
educating them but that are instead
indoctrinating them.
So that's what it looks like to me.
Blank.
We often focus on the fact that they
tried to restrict our use of language,
but I also see that there's a focus on
redefining the terms,
trying to redefine the key of language.
And uh,
by way of example,
I would say genocide,
the term which is,
you know,
fell in love,
the historical significance.
It's very powerful.
Parts of Alvin brought them
and there were other
following.
Thank you very much.
Restrict.
Sorry I wasn't ignoring you.
I had just made a whole lexicon and
politically correct words today in the
car and I wanted to read it,
but unfortunately I can't find it.
So yeah,
no one only do they redefined,
but they also,
uh,
produce new words neologisms constantly.
And one of the things I want to do is
I'm going to make a video.
I'm going to collect all these words.
I'm going to do it properly.
I'm going to go through a very large
corpus of postmodern work.
I'm going to pull out the buzzwords,
I'm going to rank order them in terms of
their frequency.
And then I'm going to make a video for
parents and for freshmen and it,
with the checklist,
it says you go through the courses and
if there's one of these words,
you check them off this list.
And if there's more than,
you know,
if you,
if the course scores more than five out
of whatever on this list,
and don't take that course unless you
want to join the cult.
And so yeah,
really,
because I thought about this,
you know,
because one of the things I proposed,
it's a kind of a radical solution.
I probably proposed it when I was a
little more angry than I should've been.
I thought one of the things the
provincial government should do is cut
the funding to higher education by 25%
and let,
let the God damn intellectuals fight
among themselves until they straightened
out the university hierarchies and
decide which disciplines are valid in
which aren't.
Now there's a problem with that.
Well,
there's a problem,
a couple of problems with that is that
first of all,
it would wreak havoc with the
universities and that's,
that's not it.
That's not a good idea.
The second is you got to watch it when
you're trying to control the free
exchange of academic ideas by top down
Fiat,
right?
Because it's another one of those
radical social experiments that might go
wrong and probably will cause it might
be you that decides what shouldn't be
taught in universities now,
but God only knows who it's going to be
in three or four years.
Right?
So,
so it's a problem.
But I think one of the things that
should be done is that people should be
educated so that they can determine
which of these courses are like that in
which professors and then just stop
attending the classes.
Now that's happening anyways,
by the way,
cause the enrollment in the humanities
has plummeted since the 1960s and the
reason and the humanities are at the
core of the university,
make no mistake about it.
If the humanities goes,
the universities are done,
but so they're already destroying their
own market viability even though they
keep bringing more and more people into
the universities and colleges.
But I think that needs to be
accelerated.
What has to happen is that the,
the,
the postmodernist radical types need to
be cut off at the source.
Students need to stop going to their
classes.
And so that means that high school
students and freshmen and the parents of
those people need to know what to look
out for.
And so,
yes,
I'm very cognizant of their use of
language.
It's also why I oppose bill [inaudible].
It's like,
I'm not going to say words that other
people demand that I say I'm not going
to do that.
And the reason that I'm not going to do
that is because there isn't anything
more important to me.
Then the,
the fact that I have then the fact that
I know I haven't got that right.
There's nothing more important to me
than the responsibility I have to honor
the words that I believe to be true.
I'm not using someone else's words and
bill see 16 by the way,
which your Senate.
So,
so a delightfully passed today makes
compelled speech part of the Canadian
legal system.
So a threshold has been crossed and you
know,
it's to help the transgendered people.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
That's not why it happened.
So you,
you don't see the language game to your
political enemies.
You do not allow them to force you to
use their terminology.
As soon as they do that,
you lose.
So,
and that was what bill [inaudible] 16
was about for me.
And there's something cool about that
too.
It was very surprising,
you know,
because
what should have,
what should have happened was that no
one paid any damn attention to the
videos I made at all.
That's what should have happened.
Or the next thing that should have
happened is,
you know,
there was 15 minute flurry about it and
then everybody went back to their
business.
That didn't happen either.
What happened was an inordinate amount
of attention congregated around this
issue and I've been trying to figure out
why ever since it's like,
wow,
you know,
something's,
something's rotten in the state of
Denmark.
There's something strange going on here.
And it certainly wasn't because what I
was talking about was about transgender
issues because it important or
unimportant as they may be at best,
they're a side issue,
right?
It's,
it's just,
it is,
it isn't something that affects enough
people to be of any requisite
seriousness.
So why all the attention?
Well,
it's because there's something real
going on underneath it.
And a lot of that is,
it's a fight over language.
That's why Derrida,
you know,
Jacques Derrida,
he criticized Western culture and he's
the head trickster of the postmodernists
fell logo centric.
That's our culture and the logos.
That speech and these people who are
passing these bills,
they are no friends of free speech.
There are no friends of free thought.
They want to put restrictions on it
cause they already know what's right and
if you disagree it isn't that you
disagree,
it's that you're wrong and you should
shut the hell up.
And if you don't want to,
we're going to figure out how to do it.
And so that's the sort of people who are
obtaining positions of power in our mid
level bureaucracies and higher.
And it's really not a good thing.
That is not the sort of people that you
want to be running things.
And some of that's because we've
abdicated our responsibility to run
things.
The competent people have bucketed their
responsibility to run things themselves.
You know,
they've abandoned politics and they
don't serve on the school boards.
They don't run their own churches and
you know,
they leave that to other people.
It's like snot a good idea because it's
the wrong sort of people who step in to
do that.
Yup.
Yeah.
Carlton Place,
it's almost considered a suburb,
the bottom and now you can see the steam
rising from Ottawa and commonplace over
the issue of
CRTC is comprised of an idea for some
French Canadians and that doesn't sit
well with the rest of the 76% of the
population,
all the others.
Um,
I wondered if you had some feedback on
how this can be improved because
bilingual is really,
in my opinion,
is a farce.
It was merely a means getting out
population.
When you get 98% of one particular
federal government
that is totally French Canadian,
then this is not an equitable situation.
Most of them there,
let's discuss with somebody who was
getting the hiring.
He was French Canadian,
Ottawa.
They simply say,
you must fight for your rights,
but there's nothing to fight about all
the people doing the hiring or a French
Canadian.
And so,
okay,
well that's also a really hard question.
So
yeah,
see a lot of,
in my way of thinking,
a lot of the entrance of the idea of
group writes into the Canadian.
Paula de was a consequence of our
attempt to serve the country together
when the separatist movement was at its
peak.
And we did so the country together
twice,
right?
I mean it damn near fell apart and that
probably wouldn't have been a good
thing.
So what we paid a price for it and the
price we paid was that we left the
specter of group rights,
enter our common law policy essentially.
And a lot of what's happening now is,
uh,
is the price that we're paying for that,
having given that diagnosis,
I don't have any cure to offer.
I don't know what can be done about
that.
My suspicions are it's the kind of
problem that has to be solved at a micro
level,
you know?
But I,
I don't know enough about the specific
issue to,
to offer anything other than that.
I understand why you would find that
frustrating.
I've thought similar things about the
way the federal government is
constituted.
On the other hand,
we've managed to keep the country and
there was a sacrifice to be made for
that.
So
apart from saying,
you know,
I get the problem,
I don't have anything to offer on that.
So Yup.
So I'm actually only going to take one
more question because I'm tired enough
so that I'm probably going to say
something stupid.
And since this is taped,
well you know,
you go to watch that because you don't
want to say any more stupid things than
necessary.
So
I a little uncomfortable talking to you
because some of what you said really
made me a little uncomfortable,
but I think that's what we have to do.
We have to be uncomfortable some of the
time.
Uh,
when you talked about don't send your
kids to take humanities,
I kind of went,
what are you talking about?
That's crazy.
I think what you're saying is the way
it's structured now,
it's,
there's dangers.
So I guess my question is where do we go
if you get the critical thinking skills
that we need,
how do we develop them?
Uh,
you said the,
you want high school students and
parents to be aware of what the problems
are.
Where are they going to get these
critical thinking skills and develop a
certain resilience to a changing world
around them?
So where would you direct us to go?
Yeah,
well the first thing I should say is
like,
I'm a great admirer of the humanities
psych and of the university.
So I mean the,
the humanities,
you learn to be a citizen through the
humanities.
The humanities are at the core of
western culture.
If they go,
we're in trouble.
So the problem is,
is that what's manifesting itself as the
humanities in the universities is no
longer the humanities.
It's something almost virtually the
opposite of that.
And so,
and so when I tell people not to go to
humanities courses in the universities,
it's with a very heavy heart.
Believe me,
you know,
now the question is,
where do you go instead?
Well,
that's a good question.
You can always read.
You know,
one of the things that's really cool
about Amazon is all the great books are
free.
They're literally free.
You can go download them on your kindle
for nothing.
The copyright has expired and people
have been putting electronic versions
online.
So the great books of the Western world
and even many of the great books of the
20th century are now available
completely for free.
Well,
so you can read them.
There's lots of information to be
garnered now on youtube and that's
really going to explode over the next 10
years.
And I mean,
one of the things I want to work on
probably over the next 10 years is to
set up a humanities university online.
And what I'm starting to work,
I already have some programs online,
they're called self authoring programs
and they help people,
right?
And partly we designed them to help
people learn to write as well as to help
them write about themselves.
So the self authoring programs help
people write an autobiography and
analyze their personality,
faults and virtues and lay out a future
for themselves.
And when we've had students do that,
do the future program,
it's so cool.
What happened was that,
um,
there the probability that they would
stay in school went up by about 30% but
something even cooler happened.
It worked best for the worst performing
students.
So we did a lot of it in Holland who at
a business school called Erasmus.
Uh,
there's a,
there's a school of management,
Rotterman,
Rotterdam School of management at
Erasmus University and we ran several,
think it's about 10,000 people through
the future authoring program now.
And what happened if you looked at the
academic performance of the students,
the Dutch women,
the native Dutch women were at the
pinnacle and then it was the Dutch men
below them.
Now the women were in a minority and
they were probably a little more highly
selected,
right.
So maybe that accounted for the
performance gap.
And then underneath that there was
female,
non Western ethnic minority immigrants
and then below that were male,
non Western ethnic minority immigrants.
And there was a massive gap between the
Dutch women and the male,
non Western minority immigrants.
Like if performance gap of about 80% a
massive gap within two years after
writing the future authoring program.
The male non-ethnic Western minority
students pass the Dutch students.
Yeah.
And some of them didn't even remember
that they had done the future authoring
exercise.
And we replicated that at Mohawk
College.
Just a while back.
Same thing.
The young men who went to Mohawk
College,
they did this exercise in the summer
just before they went to college.
They only took about an hour to write
out their future.
It's not that long to think about your
whole future.
And what happened was that the young men
who had the worst grades in school who
are in non career oriented trajectories
had a retention improvement of about 40%
so yeah,
so that was just like,
we're just thrilled about that.
So,
so the reason I'm telling you all of
this story,
apart from the fact that it's vaguely
interesting is that,
um,
we are experimenting with technologies
to teach people how to write.
Now normally the way you're taught how
to write is by having someone edit your
writing.
But that's prohibitively expensive.
I don't think it,
it,
it can be transformed in something
that's available on a mass basis.
And so what we're trying to do is to
break down the process of writing into
its requisite steps.
That's kind of what behavioral
psychologists do.
We've done that already a bit with
these,
with this essay writing format,
and then to,
to sort of teach people what the
mechanics of writing actually are,
and then maybe to try to figure out how
to crowdsource editing so that many,
many people can participate in the
process.
But we'd like to set up an online
humanities university over the next 10
years.
And since the universities have
abandoned their intellectual property,
there's no reason not to just move in
and take it as far as I can tell.
So that's the plan.
Well,
thank you.
Thank you very much for,
thank you very much for coming out and
listening to me.
And,
uh,
you know,
it was a quite interesting in all of
that.
And so,
uh,
I was a pleasure to have spoken for you.
Hey,
my pleasure,
man.
[inaudible].